Speaker 1: This might truly be the most
interesting Republican primary that I have
ever been involved in covering by far even more
than 2016. We now have video of Ron DeSantis on
the Fox News program hosted by Jesse Waters.
And Jesse WATTERS brings up to day Santos,
Trump's increasingly frequent and unhinged attacks
against him. And for now, DeSantis. His approach
has been to take the high road. I don't know
that that will work, but that has been DeSantis
approach so far. Let's take a look at how
DeSantis responded yesterday when confronted
with the recent comments of Donald Trump.
Speaker 2: All right. Well, former President
Donald Trump definitely thinking
about you. You haven't said a lot.
I know you've heard what he said. And you can
see this collision is coming, can't you? Yeah.
Speaker 3: Well, look, Jesse, I mean, you know,
he used to say how great of a governor I was, and
then I win a big victory. And all of a sudden, you
know, he had different opinions. And so you could
take that for what it's worth. But, you know, at
the end of the day, I think one of the reasons
I've been successful as governor is I don't really
pay attention to a lot of the background noise.
I mean, you know, he's obviously a big, big fish,
but I get attacked all the time. Right. Different
angle. And you either put points on the board or
you don't. And so I just focus on delivering the
wins. And I think we've done a pretty good
job of following through on our promises.
Speaker 1: So this is super interesting. There's
two interesting things here. One is this is
the first willingness we're really seeing
from DeSantis to actually go at Trump. Now,
you might say, David, that's very light. All he's
saying is Trump used to praise DeSantis and now he
doesn't. Yeah, right. But that's one of the big
things that Trump does. And Trump doesn't like
being called out for it, which is he he doesn't
praise or criticize people based on whether
he genuinely thinks they're doing a good job or
not. He praises or criticizes people based on how
they treat Trump and whether what they're doing is
useful to Trump. So first thing they're that the
Santos is doing is calling out Trump's hypocrisy
and how Trump's opinion of people just wavers
based on what's good for Trump. Secondly, the
other interesting thing here that we are seeing
is that DeSantis is starting to lay the groundwork
for approaching this campaign from the perspective
of Trump's just like another guy. And he even
says in there, I get attacked all the time.
And while he concedes Trump's a big fish, he is
basically suggesting Trump is no different in
any serious way than everybody else who attacks
him. And Trump doesn't see himself as being like
everybody else. Trump wants to be exalted and held
above everybody else. So DeSantis saying, I get
attacked all the time by all sorts of people. He's
just grouping Trump in with everybody else, which
Trump is not going to like now. And, you know,
DeSantis talks about his wins, and I mentioned
this in the last segment a little bit. Florida,
a 12th highest COVID death rate per capita. It's
completely mediocre in terms of crime. It's right
in the middle. Completely mediocre on health care.
Completely mediocre on infrastructure. Not one
of the worst. Nowhere near the best. You know,
it's sort of like Florida. We're way better than
Mississippi and Arkansas on all of these metrics,
but we're nowhere near New York or Massachusetts
or Connecticut on any of this stuff. And I like
Florida as a place to go, but it's not like they
have a great record for DeSantis to actually
write home about. His accomplishments are things
that are virtue signals, as I mentioned before,
you know, the banning CRT. We're going to have
wrestling matches really early in COVID because
we want to and taking control of Disney
because it went woke the Anti-woke act,
the don't say gay bill. That's the sort of thing
that DeSantis is known for. One other funny moment
from this interview. It really seemed like Jesse
WATTERS for a moment thought DeSantis was going to
announce his run on his program. Didn't happen.
Speaker 2: I mean, you're obviously running for
president. You got the book. You're going
around the country doing these events.
And what's going on here, Governor? I have.
Speaker 3: I've got. Well, I'm proud of I'm proud
of what we've done in Florida. A lot of people
ask me how you do it. Yeah, but I've got over
the next few months, I've got a big legislative
session. We just want a big reelection victory.
I made a lot of promises. We're going to deliver
on those promises. So finished reading the book,
I'm happy to come back and discuss that
with you, but I'd like to come back over
the next three months and discuss a lot of these
legislative wins that we're having. For example,
we're going to make sure our universities are.
Speaker 1: So now he's just going to talk about
something else. He doesn't actually
want to address the presidency.
Speaker 3: Thing from this ideology.
And that's going to be a great bill
to be able to sign here coming up very soon.
Speaker 2: All right. Well, former President
Donald Trump definitely thinking about you.
Speaker 1: Okay. So then we get into the
thing we looked at before. Okay, So descent
is not ready to announce yet. He's starting
to criticize Trump. But there's something even
more interesting that the DeSantis campaign,
the DeSantis administration
did. Let's talk about that next